j'accueille emilie frèche
françois ennemis vous avez 30 ans est
romancière scénaristes ont publié chez
panama la mort d'un pote et le pote
c'est ilan halimi alors poteau sens de
touche pas à mon pote pour vous dites
vous le crime du gang des barbares
marque la fin d'une époque
la fin d'une certaine idée de la france
celle dans laquelle vous avez été élevé
en fait oui si vous voulez moi quand
j'ai quand j'ai découvert la photo dylan
halimi dans la presse je nous ai tous
vus les enfants de ma génération une
génération qui qui a eu la chance de
grandir avec l'anti racisme qui a été
bercée par le slogan touche pas à mon
pote et était vrai que tout d'un coup
j'ai eu envie de pousser ce cri parce
que parce que c'est vrai que j'ai eu
peur et je crois que si c'est moi qui ai
écrit ce livre est pas un autre écrivain
de mon âge c'est aussi parce que j'avais
publié il ya deux ans un roman qui
s'appelle sourire de l'ange
j'avais écrit ce livre à la suite d'un
travail que j'avais fait sur le racisme
dans une banlieue à côté de mulhouse et
ce livre ça se passait dans une banlieue
c'était une histoire d'amour entre un
juif et une musulmane et c'est vrai que
tout d'un coup j'ai eu l'impression
qu'on m'avait pas entendu dans ce livre
alors au cimetière de pantin lors de
l'enterrement de ilan vous dit en fait
c'est la république que j'enterre quoi
et oui parce que si vous voulez ce qui
est terrible dans cette histoire c'est
que nous on était tous là black blanc
beur tous les copains on est une espèce
d'union sacrée à lutter contre le
racisme dire tout d'un coup tu sais le
racisme qui devient blague angleur et
c'est ça qui est terrible
alors c'est vrai que c'est une france où
une jeune fille accepte de venir à pas
pour 3000 euros oui c'est à dire que
pour moi je crois que ça nous a
finalement beaucoup aidés qu'ils s'auto
proclament des barbares parce que
finalement s'ils sont des barbares il se
trouve en dehors de la société il ne
nous ressemble pas moi je crois au
contraire que c'est des enfants de leur
génération une génération qui pour
laquelle existe cette tentation barbares
d'ailleurs qu' on est dans une société
consumériste où on n'existe que parce
que l'on possède et on n'a pas affaire
là à des repris de justice à des
délinquants
on a affaire à des jeunes filles et des
un homme comme on en croise tous les
jours qu'ils sont tombés dans cette
tentation barbare pour de l'argent 3000
euros pour appâter un mec qui va être
séquestré torturé humilié finalement tué
oui
et finalement quand les deux des
géoliers qui ont été interrogés par par
les enquêteurs ils ont dit on voulait
s'acheter des vêtements
ouais le concierge aussi finalement qui
loue un local destiné à la séquestration
d'ilan halimi pour 15 100 euros là on a
affaire avec avec tous avec ses vingt
personnes qui sont sous les verrous
aujourd'hui à des gens finalement
normaux qui tout d'un coup ne se sont
peut-être pas rendu compte des choses
enfin donc moi je ne cherche pas dans ce
livre incriminé ces gens
simplement j'aimerais qu'on s'interroge
on se dise mais est-ce que nous aussi on
risque de tomber dans cette tentation
barbare pour 3000 euros est ce qu'on
serait capable de ça alors vous dites
show fans a choisi un juif parce qu'ils
pensent que tous les juifs sont riches
mais donc le crime a une dimension
antisémite et c'est ce que dit sarkozy
quand il dit c'est de l'antisémitisme
par amalgame
si vous voulez moi je veux bien croire
que youssouf fofana est un antisémite
qui s'ignore s'il est capable dans le
même temps de dire j'ai choisi un juif
parce que les juifs sont riches et dans
le même temps de dire je ne suis pas
antisémite c'est qu'il ne sait pas ce
que c'est que l'antisémitisme
donc moi je suis d'accord que youssouf
fofana soit un antisémite qui s'ignorent
ce que je n'accepte pas c'est que nous
ignorons sont antisémites vite
qu'aujourd'hui dénoncer l'antisémitisme
c'est plus lutter contre le racisme mais
c'est prendre parti pour les juifs
oui je crois que c'est le gros souci et
moi ce qui dans cette affaire m'a
énormément
choqué il m'a fait mal c'est la position
du premier ministre d'annoncer que
l'antisémitisme avait été retenu comme
circonstance aggravante dans cette
affaire à l'occasion du dîner du crif
comme si l'antisémitisme était devenu un
problème communautaire et non plus
républicain comme si les citoyens
français de confession musulmane
catholique les athées les bouddhistes
n'était pas concerné par un crime
raciste vite qu'on le veuille ou non
l'antisémitisme et revenez en france
aujourd'hui c'est les chiffres le
prouvent
il n'y a pas des zones de non droit en
fait c'est des zones étrangers
c'est à dire qu'il ya des petits irak
des petits afghanistan dans notre
société
vous savez quand swan est morte cette
jeune française de 19 ans de confession
musulmane qu'elle a été brûlée dans une
cave
ça sera dit ma soeur est morte comme
meurent les femmes en afghanistan et et
je crois que pour ilan c'est la même
chose je crois que les vidéos qui ont
reçu les parents dylan il ya peut-être
simplement des gens les familles de jean
paul kauffmann de florence aubenas ou de
dire de daniel pearl qui ont pu recevoir
ça je crois qu'il ya une importation de
ces tortures qui se pratique dans des
pays en guerre et qui aujourd'hui
fleurissent dans les appartements de
certaines cités il faut pas aller
chercher aussi loin ni en avance ni en
afghanistan ni ailleurs cette barbarie
elle est beaucoup plus près de chez nous
qu'on ne le croit au cinéma quand on va
voir des films comme seven qui sont des
films cultes ou autre enfin il ya des
choses monstrueuses
on voit des films d'horreur qui seront
autorisés à des mômes de 10 12 14 ans
qui ne font pas la part des choses et
donc de ce fait même et ben forcément
ils sont imprégnés ça des douanes les
gens mais complètement et je sais que
parfois les inspirer mais complètement
et il ya je suis certaine qu'à des bd
des fous furieux
au départ ils ne sont passés des mômes
comme les autres qui vont tout d'un coup
parce qu'ils sont influencés parce
qu'ils vont se projeter dans un univers
cinématographique ou télévisées ou autre
se dire bauthian bruit se fait ben tiens
c'est super seven je ne sais quel
entrevoir
l'infection quand j'étais petit je mate
et des filles j'étais personnes aussi
bien qu'un film c'est l'éducation qui
est nul
si vous tout reprendre c'est tout non
mais c'est l'éducation le respect des
autres mais aussi l'inde ou au contraire
tu commences à faire des de la censure
des choses comme ça par été non la vraie
alors en rayon pour veiller à
l'éducation c'est vrai que jamais
personne a expliqué chef du au cerveau
du gang des barbares que finalement dans
l'allemagne nazie
les juifs sont riches c'était la base de
la propagande quoi donc lui comme
personne ne lui a dit c'était la base de
la propagande nazie il le pense non moi
je crois que aujourd'hui en france en
2006 où on n'a pas le droit de ne pas
savoir ce à ses yeux sous séquestre
youssouf fofana est français il est né
en france il a été à l'école de la
république il ne peut pas ne pas savoir
ça youssouf fofana il a 26 ans j'en ai
j'ai été à l'école de la république à
l'école publique moi j'ai appris ça
pourquoi pas lui il a séché les cours
depuis en troisième il a séché les cours
barlin à l'école c'est plus les parents
j'ai eu un sentiment c'est plus marrant
car l'école à l'école de la république
j'ai appris ça mais est ce que tu es sûr
que tu as pris ça à l'école ou dans ta
famille avec des parents qui ont à payer
à une certaine éducation à faire ta g
j'avais des professeurs qui faisait
venir des gens comme claude lanzmann
pour nous pour nous parler de ça qui
venait venir des témoins les survivants
mais voilà peut-être que n'a pas
fréquenté les mêmes écoles enfin je sais
pas mais en tout cas en tout cas si
partons du principe que youssouf fofana
ignorent cela très bien ce n'est pas une
raison pour ignorer son antisémitisme ça
très étrange je vous racontais zéro
suppression ça a pas si loin que ça je
crois que c'est un barbare le mec sain
et l'hôte et le gamin il aurait été il
aurait été cateau et leur ai dit j'aime
pas les cathos ça a été pareil ce qui
vous laisse aussi un fou et puis voilà
il vous tuer les gens et il y en a plein
des gens qui veulent tout je suis
d'accord avec vous mais dans cette
affaire il y a jean paul revient à 20
personnes sous
et vers où ça a duré trois semaines 21
jours c'est long 21,5 je vais mais je
dis ce que je pense que le fait que ces
gens là n'étaient pas tous fous c'est ça
la toute la vie m'a dit que c'était fou
j'ai dit que le fait de dire qu'il était
antisémite
au bout d'un moment ils donnent une
comme si donné une conscience politique
à sa barbarie et moi je france n'a pas
pu monter mais attendez je crois qu'il
ne faut pas forcément avoir une
conscience politique pour être raciste
ou pour être moi j'oublie mon saut je
dirais pas ça je vous dis parce que
désuni simplement c'est intéressant
soyons d'accord
ce que je veux dire c'est antisémite ça
fait classe qui va lui dire ça pas plus
loin que ça
moi je crois que évidemment c'est un
crime crapuleux je commence le texte par
sa sur la dimension générationnelle de
ce crime
et en parlant justement de ce que vous
disiez tout à l'heure c'est à dire
l'appât du gain ensuite j'embraye sur la
dimension antisémite c'est comme les
juges l'ont retenu une circonstance
aggravante
je ne dis pas que c'est uniquement un
crime antisémite mais je dis que la
dimension antisémite
elle est bien elle est bel et bien réel
parce que quand quelqu'un dit j'ai
choisi j'ai choisi un juif parce que les
juifs sont riches et qu'il est allé
faire des repérages boulevard voltaire
en désignant des commerces et en sachant
que ça appartenait à des juifs parce que
c'était faire fermer pendant des fêtes
pire tous les juifs étaient
potentiellement des ch'ti bhl et on sait
aussi par rapport à l' enquête que 1 ap
1 n'avait pas réussi à séduire à séduire
quelqu'un et youssouf fofana lui aurait
dit mais ce n'est pas grave il n'est pas
juif
donc je veux dire voilà c'est tout donc
évidemment on est dans un crime
crapuleux mais on a cette circonstance
aggravante de crime antisémite cette
dimension antisémite qui vient s'ajouter
au crime crapuleux
merci d'avoir été avec
amy presse d'avant match
puis